hello and welcome to this video which is
covering the third round of this year's
town of steel tournament and after admit
that I'm not entirely comfortable in
doing this video but I still do it
because it's a bit difficult to Anna
later stage I'm not so comfortable
because there's one game which is so
complicated that I didn't really feel
like him I can tell you something
totally conclusive but yeah I'm so busy
on tuesday so the only chance that i do
a video then it's not going to be a
couple of days old it's like do it right
now yeah I cannot do it on tuesday so
let's get going we had a couple of
interesting games today and now i'm
going to focus on the three decisive
games there were four drawers and those
weren't all that exciting and raking
plate white against Carlton a plays
plays very close to the vest forcing a
draw early on Elian off with white was
in slight trouble actually against Hari
Krishna important game for the standings
but it wasn't so exciting I don't think
I should necessarily yeah shorty in the
video we have to also the game watershed
Giri which ended in a draw that is solid
game I don't think there was something
for either side something very very
spectacular and then there was the game
audubon Aronian ending in a draw fatty
correct draw I think so we have three
games to look at and I'm going to start
with kayaking with wide against Duke
renovating and you can rent form a
surprise here with b6 going for the past
that's pretty rare in his opening
practice since that yeah involvement up
to playing a Sicilian here in this
situation I don't know if he actually
played The Perks before probably not um
if he did it's not something is very
regular so kayaking plays the Austrian
attack here with F
for this is what he usually does in fact
them this line is not that popular on a
higher level I'm not quite sure why that
is so it always felt quite principle to
me but ok then really place a main line
with 96 here um blank also have some
other options most popular is maybe the
move Knight a six in order to play c5 ok
if I've played by hijacking lets them
one of the two big possibilities casuals
is the other one and yeah all this seems
I think fairly logical black develops
the bishop and we after these moves we
see a position quite common for this
variation black has this Bishop on g7 it
look at this pawn chain and it is
absolutely mandatory for black to attack
this pawn shade you should not just sit
and wait or play something slow he has
to break this open with f6 this is a
good move long casual um and now when
will it took only five this initiates a
big technical tactical sequency in the
center yes let's check d takes d5 yeah
and already here very early on we come
to a critical situation here I've been
really absolutely had to play the move
Queen 36 and this wasn't all that bad
for black gave the Queen comin to e6 and
so what should why do most interesting
maybe is Bishop to g5 if white takes it
like is just going to recapture and this
is not that bad you know there's some
pressure on d5 and in many cases we will
have from yeah a huge amount of
exchanges in the
for example something like a 3d yeah
just one way of playing it and here the
likelihood of the draw i think is pretty
high White has a slightly better
structure but it feels quite George the
main thing is that what when really
played did not work you played night xe5
and this actually has a huge technical
problem 95 this is correct chan chan and
now this was the technical idea that you
had a former dutch number one hand
however this has a big big hole as white
can take on g6 and this is now extremely
problematic for black the queen it's
attacking the bishop here on g4 and
black helmet just easily move the bishop
as this bishop has this job of
protecting the hook it's extremely
awkward for black he tried to move rook
to d6 and yeah maybe this is one of the
best practical tries the position is
objectively and lost already here but
kayaking now did not play in the best
possible way yes the bishop is attacked
right now took this bishop but it seems
that the move Bishop d3 was a lot
stronger according to the computer it's
not a super 8 to a terrible still
surprising that kayaking did not play it
yeah what's the deal the bishop is
protect and also there is the threat of
night esra of Queenie for threatening
both checkmate and the bishop with a
check the critical line is probably this
check here yet after which white should
not take but play kings you want
stronger smooth and black has not solved
his issues still there's clearly for
around
taking the bishop is of course also an
option if the circumstances are correct
for example this move 24 and now
something like look at one jack is the
funniest line yeah Bishop takes
techniques but one can do this you see
this is not super intuitive okay but on
the other hand it's quite clear that
this should be a wait for wine in the
game after Queen takes rook takes and
Queenie form White was better but it
wasn't necessarily winning however the
position is much easier for why to play
as the Queen assists a very mobile piece
and can take black spawns like spawn
structures not very coordinated this is
ultimately probably too difficult to
defend in a practical game and when
really didn't didn't manage and why has
a simple plan just pushing the queenside
horns and this is what happened and
black doesn't get any decent
coordination one reason is also that his
king is permanently week on h8 yeah
black would need some crowd to play with
the pawns but you cannot push the e pawn
as it needs to be the anchor for the
bishop hair like this and the age point
you cannot push because then you expose
your king even more and that's not going
to be yeah possible to survive in the
game there was just one more nice moment
j can fast forward a little bit yeah and
this was here that kayaking actually was
able to sacrifice the Queen he could or
he took this pawn and allowed in this
situation and it was not known that he
too connected passes are tough to defend
against for look and those two
pause they do the trick okay yeah he
haven't really resigned he will not be
able to stop the palms yeah a game that
was almost decided we can say with one
move this 9065 after which ki can could
have one even more convincingly but the
way it went the position was just from
practical point of view extremely tough
to play the next game that we're going
to look at if the game then I mentioned
where I feel a little bit overwhelmed by
what what happened this is the game
between the Chinese yeah prodigy ye and
Russian Grand Master young depauw
watchin every don't know what is going
on this cake even with the help of a
computer feel like I have no idea and
probably you just need a lot more time
but to look to check a little bit
yourself and get the help of the engine
but as I mentioned earlier I cannot like
to just don't have time on tuesday to to
look at this much deeper so I'm going to
try the best that I can we had an idol
and Bishop g5 played by the by either
the sharpest move maybe the most
technical and we get this the delayed
poisoned pawn another theoretical expert
at all so it's tough for me to to really
point out the theoretical relevance of
this game what I know is that in recent
games the move a 3 was the most popular
why didn't all that often allow the
capture on between Oh black cannot take
because 9 a-4 traps the poor Queen I
bee7bea should be too and now the movie
5 this according to my database at least
is a normal team they have been the
abisha please have
was seen before in this position which
also looks a lot more standard let's aim
for this kind of situation after five we
enter tactics complications immediately
9 f5 of course um I mean I say of course
he spent 30 minutes on it but it hits
the move that kind of screams out to be
played in a way yeah wyd certainly does
not want to retreat the night and maybe
F takes if I first was a consideration
but ok nine and five but we can assume
that with this time spent nye what had
to play this now over the board um yeah
black when g6 again if they take on be
too there is no square for the Queen g6
bishop f2 yeah and now we are now in an
absolutely forced territory the queen is
attacked against cannot take and if the
Queen retreats after nine and six why
just wind so black has to play 95 and
now before and this is what i meant with
this is a crazy game we already have
those extremely technical complications
early on and it never gets to a
situation where you can easily assess
what happens so here both nights are
hanging black doesn't really have
anything else he has to take this one
and now he just canceled yeah I also
could have taken him and played rugby
one now there are tons of possibilities
he kept delaying the capture for one
more enemy actually now took on inform
and nine eggs e4f takes and c5 got
captured as well so at least now we have
material equality in terms of pieces
that nice
but porn-wise it's a total mess
currently you know why does five pawns
black at seven points like it's two
pawns up and he might capture on air for
this movement 17 is an interesting
moment in this game because he is the
first moment where the computer finds an
improvement over by his move he played
the capture very natural the move Queen
D fire forever also was quite
interesting and probably a bit better if
you believe the the engines analysis
Queen takes d5 is a simple threat a
possible line would be yeah Bishop g7
and now maybe look the one just
centralizing if black takes here you
should see 5 is going to be quite
awkward um yeah it says it's an
absolutely messy position Queen Bishop
e6 is also an option and yeah it
continues to be extremely complicated
this was played and yeah note that why
is time is also quite quite down already
you should be 60 blue one temple and
Bishop g4 white L is material down and
he has to yeah make something happen
Bishop g4 makes perfect sense the bishop
e6 is kind of anchoring the anchor of
blacks position it's a protected by a
seven and protects f7 and it kind of
ties the whole thing together rook e8
and 5v five forces played first we
should h4 activating this bishop and now
g8 and you get 6 which is a strong move
tempo and on the Queen yeah if the three
takes d5 White has the tactical short
group takes a six squad nice so black
cannot capture just me yep and white
will have a dangerous attack the engine
doesn't really give why the huge
advantage but this I feel should be good
for why they're just looks very
dangerous this is what i meant I'm not
totally sure you know those kind of it
positions you cannot just give the
compute ends and then let it calculate
for five seconds and then you say okay
I've got it you really have to look more
closely so I'm a little bit i'm unsure
about many things here Queens you force
plate and between the two covering the
main on g2 yeah 27 after this white is
getting a definite advantage Queenie six
probably was better maybe what happens
they trade and he sinks was overlooked
when I palmiotti maybe I known right now
with some material but what is not clear
to me at all if this material
configuration is actually a big
advantage or not Black has to take with
this yeah this is too easy okay so take
with this room f7 and look 25 otherwise
if black and covers this yes the whole
piece will get lost so this is the way
to just lose the exchange okay after
some intermediate moves a four by the
way this looks an important move a form
why it keeps the a pond you should not
trade on before and we'd use the porn
count even more this is sometimes the
problem if you have an extra exchange if
the porn count is dwindling down
more the exchange doesn't mean all that
much and ta for is important to keep an
ape on so we get this ending with y to
be an exchange other and then this is
ending is extremely extremely tough to
to evaluate there are many many critical
situations there is one situation a
little bit later than repetition forth
and then ye tries to continue just this
this one here b3 was interesting this is
something that at least I could could
look at a little bit it's interesting
trying to get a quick blip on it seems
to be maybe better than C 3 but again
i'm not very confident yeah yeah Luke c5
check check came back I guess notifying
that was my analysis look-see for b2 yet
and the thorniest issue like an exchange
down full exchange but the pawn is very
very strong and be true I'm not sure
that it leads to a win a line that I
continued a little bit actually ended in
a position that seems okay yeah like an
even give this up chan chan up to this
position and blacks idea now is rook c8
and takes on c 2 i'm not sure that this
is a win absolutely not that could be a
draw and the combination of this bishop
and this pawn is certainly worth a look
and get specifics in the positioner also
not helping wide i'm not sure maybe
there is some some very precise way for
y2 to make something out of this but
I feel black hairs fair drawing chances
him this was played in the game c3 and
also this part of the game I mean I can
absolutely not tell you precisely what
was going on it's clear that why does
fighting for win with the black Bishop
being a little bit stock they own age
six the bishop has a hard time to find
fine good squares but it demands extreme
precision here in this position like
always has potential for breakthroughs
here to let the sea porn or beep on
could become dangerous so I'm really not
not quite sure about the about this part
of the game it's a little bit later i
can i can tell you something check about
the position and got here and now we get
more stuff traded the thing is that
there are still many endings and
exchanged a better that that i'm not
going to be going to be winning you
cannot even trust the engineer all that
much so b3 it comes traded and look c7
ya hear my engine said route takes you
for maybe that was more precise but i'm
not i'm not entirely sure yes I civ
moment I think comes a little bit later
we can go ahead a little bit okay and
see that black managed to reduce the
porn count which is an absolute key
thing and jay jay jay so go to the
critical position got this ending and
here yeah in this position um blah
can draw with the right move he has to
go actually those moves draw but he has
to be a very precise I'm sorry here we
have the key position we formed this
position is actually a draw yes I have
screwed up my nose in him this position
is actually a draw but black has to find
the only move to draw which is Bishop to
see one this ending is actually yeah
quite complicated and they are tough
touched from me now to show what is
clear is what he played the views I mean
that much we can find out pretty quickly
this is the draw according to taylor
base but what he played oops I'm sorry
what he played sorry King and seven this
King King at six yeah king f6 losers
because now no actually hit bishops he
wants to draw right I totally screwed up
my nose yeah Bishop c1 still still drew
but here he must have missed something
after Luke see for the problem is simply
that Black now has no way to cover this
porn or prevent the size of change of
the position what I mean is that this is
losing as the pond promotes empty after
square and why does well within range of
the deep on and this means you have no
square to go to if you go here you lose
the pawn and other other moves are
basically the same thing here again
while discovering the two critical
square so the a porn and with it the
game gets lost yeah this ending again is
very complicated there are some
interesting points about it I remember
that for the ICC Grandmaster am
he made a series on that looking at this
ending for a very long time and have to
admit that I forgotten most of it it's
um yeah this is a game that you can
probably analyzed for a very long time
if you have the time on your hands so
white one day a pond and with it
ultimately the game so we're wind here
for by you is getting to a plus-one
scorned us and disturb them and if I'm
not mistaken the final game I want to
look at is the game between restless
soul and Richard reporter which are
caught the Hungarian player and this was
also absolutely absolutely amazing game
but I feel that I'm a little bit clearer
here compared to the other game in my
evaluation so we had a Queen's Indian
defense by transfer position and this is
this 94 line it's the old main line of
the Queen's in yet there's a very solid
reputation it's a little bit unusual to
see a report flying down such a solid
line but we get a an interesting
position pretty soonish so we have found
transposed now to a position type that
looks more like a like a king of Indian
normally this position type has a
reputation of being a little bit better
for wide and I think what happened in
the early middle game here basically
confronts and white has a little bit
more space this Bishop now here can't
got traded and what black legs um in
this position a little bit about our
porn breaks black cannot easily place
e6b 5 f-5 is not easy to play but it's
in comparison the most realistic this is
why I would prefer why
just got more space and clear ideas for
example long term white could try be 3a
three before this kind of thing on the
queenside have to prepare it properly
and but this is an idea while I'm not
quite sure what black is doing in the
meantime we got a very interesting
position now h5 was played stopping any
expansion on the king toilet but yeah so
insisted on this playing f3 idea being
g4 I was actually a bit surprised about
this plan playing on their King side
here I wouldn't have considered this
seriously I think but I mean it seems to
be okay it doesn't seem to be terrible
anything but I'm very pretty certain
that i would have gone for something
else here trying for playing on the
queenside but ok we'll see what happens
white gets this g4 and gaining a bit of
space and yeah after h5 being played by
black vistas make some sense of course
you know what might try to trade the g
pawns and then in an ideal world you
would get denied over to f5 with really
fantastic situation if you get their
King edge 72 gauge one glue g8 I think
this is all kind of logical and black
activated his Bishop to h6 yeah very
very key moment now in the game and the
starting point now of some really
creating complications up to this point
this game mum yeah doesn't look like
anything out of the ordinary it could
well as bit some game and a cop off
against Valerie solo from the 1990s but
now crazy things happen after move like
93 the position is probably equal
but this was played by soul and I think
he probably just missed the next move I
mean I don't think you just walk into
this reply all right let's say that's
the wrong way to phrase it I don't think
you you play accepting that this moves
in the position report now played a
really really great move we should be
want and it's always something that you
should play if it's kind of possible you
cannot have to play it yeah putting in
the bishop here on the on the back rank
actually on the starting square for
whites bishop of course the simple idea
is that ok here's a big fork and with
why not being able to take it black is
attacking the pond and if you cover it
like with the Queen let's say with this
like is taking it ok because yes just
the same Fork there so it's not actually
easy for why to react to that yeah so
what what to do yeah soldiers play 93
giving up the pawn and now it's gone
it's really funny by the way we should
check what happens after be three after
be three black cam yeah well there's a
couple of ideas but I think this is a
good one maybe try and this you can try
Bishop b2 as well but that's a bit yeah
ok probably a bit too much so this
happened and he put the night on b5 yeah
so how is black going to recover this
bishop on be to its kind of stranded it
seems yep there is a way you just go
back to see one again having this is
great yes this bishop this has a real
great journey from g7 h6 see won't be
too back to see one it's really great ok
so h5 could take it
and the position is not good for white
really not and he had overlooked this
Bishop see one idea so yeah takes Bishop
f4 93 and now I think I'm yeah a very
very nice and aggressive move by report
he plays f5 this is some I mean this is
the kind of move that you you you play
if you're extremely confident in
yourself so f5 opens up the position and
offer the pawn but after taking it upon
as we will see legs compensation will be
absolutely tremendous so yeah so I took
this Knight takes Andrew to g8 and this
looks very scary and we have to also
keep in mind that in this position and
black just have sacrificed one pawn he's
not like down a piece or something
substantial just a single port and the
idea is very straightforward he wants to
check on g2 and then play rook d2 with
tempo so then double on this segment on
here on the second rank note that the
white pieces now both looks and this
night they don't attack anything they
just are basically standing around and
don't do much especially considering
blacks King now there's no counter play
against blacks king the two looks on the
h VAR are totally useless and this
Bishop is absolutely dominating and
covering those crucial squares so in the
game king of one was for Slade and here
we have a really amazing situation Black
now has a fantastically strong move that
yeah gives gives
an advantage but it was very difficult I
think it was difficult to find but
report did job he played the right move
this is the really amazing move b5 those
breakthroughs on protective squares are
always very difficult to play yeah b5
extremely strong move so why what does
happen now we have to look at a couple
of possibilities the first one is 90 x b
5 after night XP five black plays look
g2 and invades a key idea is that if
black plays look G to immediately here
the 92 is actually defending this quite
well you have blocking the second-ranked
so then rip t2 is not possible this is
the reason why inserting this is an
achievement now root T 2 is impossible
to prevent what else if white stays and
does not react to this here then before
I was going to happen and also oops
sorry come on that also doesn't look
very yeah very good for why the tractor
is probably losing in the game so took
with the pawn and now invasion time note
if now 92 yeah then black simply takes
that's the difference queenly one was
tried by by so that sir that's a
relatively good try however this
position is completely winning from
black if he plays it correctly and the
winning move is not a very spectacular
one it is just looked it true that was
the plan all along I'm not sure what was
miss James by report really don't know
it looks very very normal to do this but
when you wanted to double on the second
rank the second idea that black also has
to bring the Queen over maybe he thought
that he wins no matter what he tried
this move intending maybe for this or
queen g6 but why just placed 92 and now
the tables have actually turned a little
bit now um black has to be careful for
example sometimes wives can actually
take him on f4 and then playing five
next if you ask the computer in will
point out that black can still hold this
position but he needs to play an
absolutely fantastic move I don't think
this is this move is totally impossible
to find but it is definitely very
difficult to find if you are in this
situation now because I'm fairly certain
that black player already had noticed
that he had missed something because you
were so utterly winning you you feel
like oh my god this is not so clear
anymore and then you lose balance and
sometimes just you have blunder it and
went completely so what was the move
that I was mentioning I think it can be
found I mean fc6 the idea is that you
need to Queen 21 yeah join the attack
and create five or something doesn't let
anything but if white takes now you have
create a seven and this is going to be
painful here black actually wins in this
particular line threatening discoveries
or and in some cases as you care to
check as well yeah like let's say I know
so some move and I t3 is also good but
you can also also do
mk4 gently formate after six actually
why it has to be cautious it has only
one more b6 covering this yeah now after
some live like this it was quite funny
and you know how it ends on okay and the
engine claimed the draw yes it's a draw
by repeating moves we probably have been
down their fair share result of this
game yeah but report did not place his
six he pled to move cringy sinks and
this simply doesn't work he must have
miscalculated something him because
after ninety seven which was played by
so black does not have a winning tactic
I mean it looks very dangerous like rook
we have to check and then on all kinds
of sacrifices but it just doesn't work
now he plays be plated through have to
but yes ultimately why this escaping
look 33 looks like a bit of a shocker so
let's move but after the simple captcha
and now the LAN yeah white can sacrifice
the Queen and now coordinate note how
nicely wise piece all of a sudden see
our work together night is covering this
the night is also shielding from all
kinds of checks like from c3 from here
it's very nice and what actually has a
meeting attack Marion with the h-bond
yeah and the night setting of the
Arabian mate yeah here they are just a
couple of checks but check this ok
adhere black is running out of spy
checks yeah an absolute tragedy by
report who played it absolutely
fantastic game after this this critical
point yeah I mean bishop see one okay
not not
really so difficult to see but it is
very aesthetic and snatching this going
back to the same way yeah and then at
five it's very powerful move and then he
even found the fantastic b5 so yeah
great stuff absolutely great stuff and
then after this somehow he mr. let's say
simple move grouped into after having
found older older yeah the key the key
moves that were difficult to see ya
really tragic and then losing with cree
t6 yeah and i'm at the end I think we
have fair to say it was a very lucky
with for for the American player for
wednesday so who now also is on a class
one score if i'm not mistaken we have a
lien of leading the event with plus two
and a couple of players with class 1
it's a very close field sm we already
the ACLU's expected perform yeah thanks
a lot for watching i would like to tell
you more about the veggie dip from jesse
game but i'm overwhelmed by it but i
still think you had a good only you what
happened in this in this round thanks
for watching